oh what we got um you've been through
coaching changes before um just kind of
how do you react when you find out that
news and how do you try to comprehend
Building from
here um you know obviously it's tough um
you know you build a relationship with
people um and all of a sudden boom they
you know they're not
here um for a coach like grief I think
from day one was everything was about
togetherness was always leading this
group
um you know into the direction that we
set in the beginning of the year and him
not being here at the end of the day you
know like we're human it's it it hurts
everybody but I then got to keep on
moving forward we have a goal in our
head which is to be the best basketball
team that we can be uh obviously there's
a lot of high expectations uh from the
ownership group from the front office
from
ourselves um to be great and this is
this is the business of the NBA you know
um I've been in a situation like that in
the past I understand how things works I
got to keep on moving forward today Joe
PR is our our head coach uh we played a
very very good game and get a very very
good team that we last by 40 uh
a week ago and tomorrow Coach P is going
to be our coach again we going to watch
film we going going let Coach uh Joe
lead us
in uh towards the direction that we've
set as I said in the beginning of the
year and
um Can to be
better um I think 38 games
left as whoever comes in to to coach you
guys just as you're like trying to think
of the idea of getting ready in 38 games
with a new coach for a playoff run do
you feel like that's enough time to to
mesh in the way that you need to to kind
of prepare for for a stretch run that's
a very good question um I didn't of the
day I I am not in meetings uh that's
been taking place with I don't know who
ultimately makes a decision like that
probably the GM and the the owners um I
this time I don't know if there's going
to be a coach uh that's going to come
and uh take over uh so I don't want to
make assumptions that there's going to
be a coach obviously there's um a lot of
media Outlets out there that have uh put
some names out there but uh as I said
today my coach is Joe priny and I got to
respect him I got to respect that and
um I cannot assume that we're going to
going to have you know uh in the near
future another another coach when that
happen I can uh I can you know comment
about that more 38 games
also do I know if it's going to be
enough no I don't know I've never been
in a position like that before I don't
know if 38 games enough to come together
and uh try to win the a
championship so I don't know we'll see
we'll see how how how it goes but I end
of the day like we we play the game
players play the game uh we getting we
getting together Chris is dunking the
ball all of a sudden dunk last game d
this game I don't know what's going
on um I made the three this game last
game too like we just switching roles
like I think I mean Chris milon is in my
body actually no I'm inan Chris milon
body he's in my body now I'm joking but
um players players play the game you
know and and at times we we need
direction but at the end of the day our
talent will take over and we we're going
to read the play we're going to make the
best uh possible
decision um and I think we've played a a
season
that guys have been healthy we've played
a lot of minutes together like me and D
we've played 40 something games together
and we going to play 70 80 who knows but
we on the court together me Chris D
Brook like we on the court so we playing
good or bad sometimes we lose sometimes
we win um sometimes
we we don't play well sometimes we play
well but it's good that we are out there
together now who's going to come and
give us that
direction um in the future I don't know
right now I know the D the guy is giving
us direction is Coach Joe and uh today
he was he was incredible uh was able to
get a win we play them again on Friday
hopefully we can get a win
again um John John was up there pregame
and said one of the factors behind the
the decision was he felt there's another
level the team there's a gear um this
team can be better and I know you just
said players play so I guess I'm curious
where do you think a this change can
help you play better as a group and get
to a different level cuz that's that's
why JN had said they made the change so
I'm curious how you feel that can help
help you all the the change yes the
change I don't know um you got to I
think Jim you got to ask
John I do believe like I can break it
down and you know go from defense
offense from my chemistry from the way
we practice from
our our our level of uh Focus you know
when we go out there like there's a lot
of things that we can do better from a
Twan game with me and day more for uh me
and Chris to also connect more from up
BR like there's so many things from not
giving up a lot of Threes like you know
today we were trying to do Sam went off
but okay um there's a lot of things that
we can do better so I probably assume
maybe I'm not sure you got that he's uh
referring to those
things